[Music]
tell me everything that happened the
first time I visited death row I wasn't
expecting to meet somebody - same ages
name from a neighborhood just like ours
could have been me mom but what you're
doing is gonna make a lot of people
upset you always taught me to fight for
the people who need the help most your
life is still meaningful and I'm gonna
do everything possible to keep them from
taking you all know what you into down
here now better when you get it from the
moment you're born God just macmillan we
done here mr. macmillan please I was
just about to give up when I got a call
from a Harvard lawyer looking to start a
legal center for inmates on death row I
was in before he even offered me the job
you'd allow you yes ma'am thank you so
much for driving all the way out here
most lawyers barely make time to call I
can't believe you talked to all my
people say you won't fight for me
I did I mean a lot you don't digging in
those wounds they're gonna be making a
lot of people very unhappy
when people care about a thing that much
don't mean anything to get what they
want when I first learned about all this
it was like looking at a river full of
drowning people not having any way of
helping them
[Music]
the equipment will set each of us is
more than the worst thing that we've
ever done I know what it's like to be in
the shadows
[Music]
it's my dad he did nothing wrong
it's never too late for justice
you know kid enough fight for me
if we can look at ourself close
we can change this world for the better
[Music]
we all need Chris
we all need mercy
I cannot sue back you get you there
telling and ain't no man gonna take
their folks
[Music]